internship that the worker has now with
the corporation and in it's an unnatural
relationship and it's a relationship
that seems to have like dehumanized
people to the point of being autumn
Atanas the don't have a sex drive that
don't deserve to be able to explore
their consciousness and this is a real
problem and what already told me what
you know already studied the Talmud and
did it for like 12 hours a day when he
was a young man yeah he told me there
was one passage where in one of the
ancient texts where it was talking about
battling a dragon and he said he's like
this doesn't make sense because
everything in here is supposed to be a
story that actually happened like what
is this dragon oh the dragon is a
metaphor for masturbation they tell him
so the dragon that takes away young boys
this is it is it is a metaphor for
masturbation didn't talk about this on
the podcast yes dude it's it's you know
Ari knows about as much as anyone you're
ever gonna meet about Orthodox Jewish
traditions and the you know oh yeah
religion and the the tax he really did
study that [ __ ] every day 12 hours a day
for years in Israel right yeah yeah so
when he tells you about it and you know
he got the Trent he got the actual
translation of the metaphor yeah from a
guy who's a scholar yeah dude yeah
that's a Chad and that it for that's
like I think like if I wanted for
whatever reason to dissuade people from
jerking off I could come up with a way
better like thing than a dragon to
represent it you know there'd be some
other thing like a I don't know man like
a what's like a what what would be like
the creature version of a rolled-up ball
of dried [ __ ] that you've thrown next to
your bed and someone walks into your
bedroom and sees the rolled-up ball of
dried [ __ ] Kleenex and it's just kind of
like that's gross you didn't clean up
your [ __ ] Kleenex it would be like one of
them Ghostbuster villains right if some
sort of
plasma thing that just Jesus all over
you yeah you know they'd get Ghostbuster
what do you think about the anti fat
movement anti fat movement FAP FAPE
oh no no jerking off yeah
no FAP not anti fat anti no it's a
different movement well there's good and
bad the good thing is sex will be way
more pleasurable the bad is it'll be way
more desirable so like to mitigate your
sexual urges so you don't do stupid
things and hang out stupid people have
sex with people you don't really like
but you think are hot cuz you're horny
yeah and they're willing which is a lot
of people they get they get roped up
with these relationships yeah these guys
and gals that they're not really in love
with yeah but they like to [ __ ] right
you know
you know it's like what do you think
about it well like I think that there
you know what I thought something always
think back on is when you were sponsored
by fleshlight mm-hmm and this is when we
were doing the podcast from your house
and I mean you'd come to do your podcast
and you'd walk away with a flashlight so
I ended up with like I don't know three
or four flashlights and like at first I
just wanted like you had different types
and at first I just went for like the
one that looks like a [ __ ] right but
then like you know it's like oh I got
that one but then you have like one that
was like I don't know man like some kind
of like gargoyle alien thing it was
really new or something it was really
[ __ ] weird man but anyway
you know I [ __ ] those things in and
and and I when I think back to it it's
like the first time I did it it tricked
my brain yeah the second time or the
third time I did it it wasn't getting
the same effect whereas when I have sex
with a human it's a completely different
it feels like it's a completely
different series of chemicals that must
be being released in my mind yeah you're
uniting with someone you're bonding with
someone you certainly get that oxytocin
from orgasming together yeah spawns
people so I've always thought generally
like if I'm in a period in my life I'm
jerking off a lot it's like usually like
there's something that imbalanced in
there like I don't mean to apply like a
sin to it at all I'm just saying like
personally yeah it feels a little
dissipative when you're doing it a lot
there I don't know I completely agree
but that's the balance but the balance
is also like you don't want to just be
horny all the time
no because when you're wanting you make
shitty decisions so you like yeah you'll
date someone just for sex yeah well you
need to like I mean I think that there
is something to be said for figuring out
how to deal with like though that kind
of energy like if you so that's a that's
an energetic state like if suddenly you
get being horny is an energetic state
yeah
it's energy like if you're really horny
and you sit and like watch the the
feeling itself it's electrical like you
can feel it moving around in your body
it like it can almost make you twitchy a
little bit like it's like a very potent
energetic state so theoretically instead
of trying to get the question would be
rather is there a way to release that
energy that isn't through the tip of my
dick in the form of DNA is there a way
for me to release that energy in other
ways or is the only way the only valve
on that to come that's a question what
do you think
I think there's when this natural
build-up happens it makes people more
easily aroused it makes people more
concentrating on sex and I think that it
that can put you out of balance - you
could be put out of balance both by too
much masturbation you can definitely be
put out of balance by too much desire
for sex yeah cuz you're just horny
should you just take care of it yourself
and you'd be relieved and then you could
think clear you know I think the body
needs a balance right that's why I'm a
big proponent of exercise